uh booster jabs in the autumn
does that suggest that restrictions in
one form
or another could be a feature of quite a
lot of 2021
well it shouldn't mean that because then
when we get to the autumn with booster
jabs in autumn they might say well we
need booster jabs
in february and then when we get to
february booster jabs
in july and so on and so forth so this
is no reason
and no excuse not to open up the economy
we were told vaccination was the route
out of lockdown
we've been in lockdown in one form or
another for many many months some
communities have been locked down for
the best part of a year
and come february 22nd we want to see a
route back to normality
isn't the problem that the threat of
variants
and looking at bristol for example where
we have this mutation of the kent
variant which is highly transmissible
and may not
be as responsive to a vaccine that that
means
unlocking we're going to see those
variants become more widespread
there are always problems uh
coronaviruses evolve
that's been known for for many decades
if not a century
so none of this should come as news to
any scientist and it shouldn't come as
news to the government it may come as
news
to the public but i'm afraid virus is
always evolved which is why we have a
different flu vaccine every year but we
don't go into lockdown
every year and we cannot continue the
way we're continuing
this is appalling for society there are
huge levels of anxiety and stress
this is a an epidemic of mental health
problems probably waiting to come around
the corner
some have already arrived we have an
economy to maintain
and i'm afraid this is just not
acceptable i think for the secretary of
state today for transport to suggest
people shouldn't
start booking summer holidays domestic
summer holidays
was an extraordinary statement to make
and a very irresponsible statement to
make
well you describe it as irresponsible
but is the government right
to be urging caution at the moment
because they've been
burned haven't they by over optimistic
statements
totally irresponsible last year summer
holidays went ahead
caseload was very low this year we have
a vaccine we have a vaccine with very
high efficacy rates so i'm afraid there
is no excuse
and it seems to me that you're
suggesting that we should just be in
permanent lockdown
because there will always be new
variants of coronavirus coming along and
if that's what you want
well i'm afraid it's not going to be
sustainable we will go bust
and we will have social unrest we will
have division
people do actually need to see the
people that they love they do need to
hug and hold their children
they do need to mix with their friends
they do need to
spend time in other people's company but
if if if you don't think that's
important and the government
don't think that's important i think
they're going to get a rude awakening uh
when the public decide that they've had
enough
i'm not suggesting anything at sir
charles at all we
all want to be with our friends and
family again we all want to
hug but you don't dear us again i'm just
asking you whether
given the fact that the prime minister
told us last year that we'd be back to
normal by christmas we weren't back to
normal by christmas were we in fact
we've seen over 100 000 deaths
yesterday we recorded over a thousand
deaths
in one day everybody wants the economy
to be opened up again
but is it the right time to be doing
that
well i hope everybody wants the economy
to be opened up again
but they will always argue that it's not
the right time just another six months
another six months we have the vaccines
we have the vaccines we were told they
were the way out of this
so we vaccinate the population but
you're still in lockdown people are
going to start scratching their heads
and start wondering what on earth is
this this all about what the government
is doing now is bordering on the very
dangerous to be perfectly honest
it is robbing people of hope it is
robbing people something to look forward
to
and it is very very stupid and very very
short-sighted
now i don't hold the prime minister
responsible for this but i do hold his
secretaries of state
responsible for this and he needs to
rein them in very very quickly
lord sumption appearing on sky news
earlier said matt hancock the health
secretary had
lost his grip on reality very angry
about the travel restrictions that were
brought in
yesterday announced yesterday to come
into force on monday and in particular
the potential sentences for those who
break the rules and lie about where
they've been what do you make of that
utterly ridiculous thing for the
secretary of state for health to say are
we really going to lock people up for 10
years
for being dishonest about the fact that
they've been to portugal by all means
give them a fine give them a hefty fine
a few thousand pounds are you really
seriously suggesting secretary of state
that we've got enough prison capacity to
start locking up 19 year old silly kids
for 10 years what a stupid thing to say
i mean a really stupid thing to say
that demeans that demeans his office and
his position around the cabinet table